Habibi, so you're stalking us, right?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no.
Habibi, come on. So, brothers and
sisters, we are heading to the studio.
Shall we continue there?
Woah.
Aki, Aki, Aki, Aki, come on. I love you.
I heard everything.
>> Aki. Wallahi, I just feel fake Muslim.
>> How? How? Habibi, Habibi, Habibi, listen
to me. Habibi, listen. Wallahi, I watch
I'm angry. That's it. Wallahi, I'm not
scared of you. I know. I'm not scared.
But, did you hear what he said? Aki, you
know what? Yeah, please. The man has
these weapons, drugs inside of the van.
They pulled up on me, 10 of them. Hey,
you. I've had a van full of drugs and
weapons, and they come and blame me.
Aki, you know what? Number plate, number
plate. You're going to call the cops,
bro. Aki, Aki, Aki, Aki.
We are teaching people how to pray.
>> And every time they pray, you get to
share in that reward. And when they
teach their children and their
children's children
the reward continues. Every Fajr Dhuhr
Asr
>> Maghrib Isha Every recitation for just
£100 you can help teach 20 to 60 people.
Like me. Learn how to pray salah. Donate
today.
Bro, same. I have I have a sincere
request. Yes. Can I join you in the
studio?
Huh? Can I join you in the studio?
Habibi, wallahi, I don't mind, but these
brothers, they're
I would love to. If you come another
day, but with these guys, I think
they're very
Even some brothers when they come, they
were very strict, you know. Me, Habibi?
We're there every day. We'll go back to
the studio. Wallahi. It's just me and
Aki, wallahi. Can you take a picture of
me and Muhammad, please? Muhammad? Yes,
yes.
Okay, when he comes back, I'll take you
take a picture of me and Muhammad, yeah?
Yes, yes.
Okay.
Yeah, I've got a sincere request. Tell
him not to pay. There's three of them.
I'll ask them one by one. Please, can I
join you in the studio just to observe?
Wallahi. said we don't mind. No, no, we
don't mind.
Habibi.
Speak.
I just heard you say you want to join
the studio.
I know, it doesn't matter, bro. I know
what you're trying to do, bro.
We We We have our own thing right now.
We're doing our own thing.
I know. Bro,
it's like you're already older. You have
wife, children. You should know better.
We're doing our own thing.
Bro, I I don't like the way you're
stalking us. That's weird.
Why are you stalking us?
Okay, so you're stalking us, right?
Yeah, you are stalking us.
Are you stalking us?
You see that, bro?
You see that? You know I'm not scared to
swing for you.
I'll swing for you.
I'll swing for you, man.
I came to the studio to
You think I'm scared of
No, wallahi.
You know what? I came to the masjid as a
sincere Muslim.
Wallahi, akhi. Do you see that?
You see how aggressive you came and
pushed me, bro?
No, no.
You know what? I dare you to touch me.
Akhi, if you're a man of Allah, touch
me.
If you're a man of Allah touch
If you're a man of Allah, akhi, touch
me.
I know. I know.
Akhi, akhi, remember what I said to you.
Are you He's upsetting. Are you I only
Man's got Man's got no friends. I only
observe you, man.
Remember what I said to you. And even
yesterday when I saw him at earth, he
was the dish He was He was looking down
upon me.
What did Habibi, what You said Habib,
you know my studio is your studio. My
studio is your studio.
But Habib, But I love and respect you,
yeah? I see what you do for Islam. I
love and respect you. Habib, wallahi
He's just so aggressive. Just hear me
out. Hear me out. I know. I know. Okay.
I want to I'm scared of breath 10 ft.
Let me speak. You know what I mean?
Okay. My studio is your studio. Come
anytime you like. No, it's all right.
Come any time, akhi, it's your bro. I
know. I'm calm.
I'm calm. What I'm saying, Habib, I told
you any time I respect you. Thank you
very much. Please please Habib. Habib. I
just you know what?
No, I know. I know. I know. I know. What
did I say to you? My heart full of love.
Islam, I love for my brothers. What did
I say to you? And I ask you sincerely
And what did I say? And what did I say?
You said they're doing nothing. I said,
"Okay." I went to Muhammad and asked
him. Good. I asked everyone
individually. And what did I say? I
said, "Habib, my studio is your studio."
All right, Habib. I appreciate it. I
mean, any other day No, I I I just need
20 minutes around the corner and I want
to go back to my wife Okay, that's fine.
Salam alaykum. Any other day, Habib, you
come. Please. Salam alaykum, man. I
would never You know what? You mentioned
being scared, bro. You mentioned only
being scared of Allah. It's Allah. I
came to you, man. You don't be scared,
man. It's only
Sneako, my brother. Wallahi, they're not
scared. They're not scared of me. Sneako
was so nervous approaching him. Why are
you scared, brother? I mean,
Why are you scared? I watched you. I
told Okay, Habib. Javi. Javi. Javi.
Javi. I'm telling you, guys. Javi, he's
right. The people looking at me like I'm
scared. Okay. Okay. Stop. I don't care,
MY BROTHER.
I SWEAR by Allah. I swear by Allah.
I swear by Allah. I swear by Allah.
Listen to me. Listen to me. I know guys
bigger and smarter than you. Wallahi,
I'll do IT IF YOU
WALLAHI, I'LL DO IT IF YOU STAND CLOSER,
OR I'LL KNOCK YOU DOWN in the car park.
Habib. Habib. Habib. Habib. You know
why? Go to the middle. Go to the guys.
Go to the guys in the middle. Go to the
guys. Can you go to the man, please?
Habib, go. Just take a walk, Habib. You
can go You can go first.
Go go go Habib. Habib, go. Wallahi, you
know I'm scared. Go go go go.
You know what I mean? Wallahi, he's
upset. Habib. Wallahi, he's upset.
Habib. Approaching Muslim brothers, I
follow Go, Javi. Javi. Javi. Please go
to the car, bro.
Relax. What am I doing? All right, it's
fine. What am I doing, Javi? Salam
alaykum, man.
You man You man in London is my guy.
Hey, peace.
Let him talk, bro. What should you go
fight?
I'm leaving, bro. What should I do? Call
him and tell him, bro?
No, apparently
Habibi, what should I do? Fight a man
who's got anger?
Bro, what should I do? Fight him in
Ramadan?
Chubby, what should I do to him? Are you
going to try something, bro? You going
to
What do you want me to do?
No, Chubby. No, no, Aki. Leave it. Leave
it. It's Ramadan, Aki. Leave it.
Come. Where's the Where's the van? Okay,
the van is there.
Okay.
Come sit down. Go away.
Be the bigger person. I'm going to make
a mess. Bad news.
Westminster
>> Don't worry about that. That's the least
of my news. I'm going to He said,
"Chubby, got bad news, mate."
Oh, I couldn't park anywhere else.
That's sad times for you, mate.
Life is hard, Chubby. Don't worry.
Okay.
Um Again, you guys going to go? I'm
going to
Yo. If If you could tell me Yeah, ask to
leave.
Okay, fine. Yeah. Okay, go.
Go go go go go. Have you got Have you
got it, Aki?
Have you got it? I don't know. I think I
think he wants to He wants the reaction.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go go go. Go go go.
Go go. Go go go. Go go. No.
That's what he wants, my guy.
Yo, let's go. Let's go. That's what he
wants. Just Go go go go. Let's go. Let's
go. Let's go. Let's go, guys.
All right, relax, Aki. Relax. Let's go.
Aki, don't don't Don't give me a
reaction. Don't give me a reaction.
Don't give me a reaction.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. He wants
He wants He wants. Anyway, leave him.
Leave him. Leave him.
Yes. I I didn't I bro I was really
And how did they find out?
Yeah.
Go, guys. Go go go go.
Go go go. Chubby, you got the keys,
yeah? Okay, go go go.
All the way you want to go? No, no, I'm
getting a cab. You guys go.
No, no, no, no.
NO, NO, NO.
>> [laughter]
>> NO, NO, COME with me. Go, go, go. We're
getting a cab. Go, go.
>> [clears throat]
>> No, bro, no. Please, just go. You're
part of it.
No, habibi.
Okay, okay, good.
Anyone who said it here, where's the
habibi?
Where habibi? Where habibi?
Where habibi?
Come, come, come.
No, no, no, you can't, you can't, you
can't.
Habibi, I see with the cab there.
Go there.
Go, Javi, go.
Javi.
Go, go, go. I see you guys there, yeah.
Where's the
Where's one?
Okay, one second.
Um
All right, bismillah. So, we're going to
head to our studios, inshallah.
Uh do do do
Bismillah.
Okay.
So, brothers and sisters, we are heading
to the studio, inshallah. We're going to
continue there.
Whoa.
Aki, Aki, Aki, Aki.
Aki.
Aki, Aki.
AKI.
AKI, NO, HE DIDN'T. HE DIDN'T.
AKI, AKI, AKI.
AKI, AKI.
NO, MUHAMMAD HIJAB HABIBI, HABIBI,
HABIBI.
I
I'M coming
And HE'S CALLING ME
I
I I DON'T
CARE. PLAY BRO, RECORD EVERYTHING BRO.
Do you know why my brother? Do you know
why I can't take a picture?
No, no, no brother, listen. I'm
following this van. I'm trying to know
where the studio is and I'm coming with
the man. I'm coming with the man them.
I'm stripping them naked.
You watch. I'm angry, that's it.
I know. I'm the man in here. But did you
hear what he said? Did you hear what he
said to me?
Come here, come here.
Habibi, listen
You're a Muslim. Did you hear that?
That's back biting us. That's what I
don't want you to say in my presence.
I want what's yours. I want what's
yours.
Don't need your help in here.
I'm coming.
But did you see him?
In front of my face. I know, I know, but
But you call yourself Muslim.
You call yourself that.
Did you hear what he said on the street?
Reverse him over. He's got tears
He's done sincere about my religion.
I'M FOLLOWING YOUR VAN. I'm telling you
right now. I'm now in the studio as
well.
Call the police my brother. I'll seize
the drugs in the van right now.
I'm coming. Listen to me. Habibi, listen
to me. Get in your car, let's talk.
Let's get in the car. Did you hear from
me? I heard it from Muhammad man. Okay,
did I say anything? He's a fake Muslim.
He is. Let's get into your car and let's
talk. I want to call the police please.
Let's go.
Come on. Yes, please there's a man
weapons, drugs inside the van. They
pulled up on me 10 of them.
I need you to call police.
I'm on Waterloo Street, 141 Waterloo
Street.
Police are here.
I've had I've had I've had a van full of
drugs and weapons. And they called
police on me. Number plate, number
plate. You're not a Muslim. You're a
Muslim.
You're a Muslim.
You're a Muslim. Okay, don't lie. You're
a Muslim.
It's from my dad. He looks like my
uncle. Habibi, it's from my dad. They
got weapons and drugs inside the
Uh Habibi, you're a Muslim.
Habibi, you're a Muslim.
Are you a Muslim? You're a Muslim. It's
from my You're a fake Muslim. I can't
Why observe?
Why observe? That was back biting us.
Finally he said get IN MY CAR. I LIKE
CALL THE POLICE IT'S CALLED THE OKAY
LISTEN. OKAY LISTEN.
OKAY.
Okay you know what I can
Okay just call the police man for this
for this guy. Now he doesn't understand
the goodness bro forget him.
I am
I am Bro wallahi he's a Muslim wallahi.
Yeah no no no no no it's good it's good
it's good.
That's all.
Bro can you
Can you
Bro excuse me.
Hello.
Hi there yeah police police.
Driving driving driving.
Hello hi there.
Hi there we're on what road is this?
What road is this?
Yeah we have someone who's causing
nuisance and trying to cause a fight.
What road is this? What road is this?
Driving driving driving by the way.
Yeah.
Yeah
yeah what road what road is this?
What road is this?
Yeah he's gone bro he's gone he's gone
let's go let's go he's gone.
Okay have you got his number plate just
in case?
Yeah.
Hello guys yeah.
So sorry we've just basically we've got
some guy who's you know he's not
psychologically psychologically not well
sadly. He's reported a false
report on our car that we've got guns
and drugs and we're gang members. We've
got it recorded on camera. I want to
give you the number plate.
The number plate of the car is Lima Fox
23. I have I have the picture I have the
picture. Papa November Alpha Papa
Uniform Yankee he's made a false report
there's there's gangs and guns and drugs
and everything in the car which is a
false report. You can come and check the
car. This is his license plate. Yeah,
and that's his number. He's not He made
a false report to the police report to
him. Yes, basically he's called the
police. He's been causing us nuisance
sadly. He's stalking us. He's stalking
us for multiple days.
>> Yeah, so his number plate he's reported
our van to have guns and drugs and stuff
in it so he can so the armed police can
stop us which is a false report. His
number plate Okay, just stay there. Stay
calm. No, it's not we're calm. I'm just
letting you know we're heading to a
specific direction. If the police stop
we don't have any of those stuff in the
car in our vehicle. No,
don't don't
leave the scene, okay? There's a unit
already on their way. Okay, I hear you.
There's a unit coming. Just stay here so
they can just clear cuz he said they got
guns. Leave the car.
They're they're likely to
likely to search you but just if you're
willing to
>> That's fine. That's fine. That's fine.
That's fine. No problem at all. Thank
you.
Uh my name is
Echo Romeo Delta India.
Echo Romeo Delta India and your surname?
It's Kilo India Lima India Charlie.
Kilo India Lima India Charlie.
My car is over there.
>> India Charlie and your date of birth?
Uh okay, 1 second.
Thank you.
Yeah, no no no, 100%. I don't blame you.
100%.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, 100%.
I'm thinking I'm thinking subhanallah.
>> You know earlier I was saying what
happened in America? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know what they do? They call up
streamers. They're like oh the streamer
is in this location. They got guns,
this, that. Bro, but it's called
swatting.
>> Really? But in America it's called it.
Bro, bro, you know apparently he's done
it to these lot yesterday. I didn't even
know. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wallahi.
Bro, you know what? Let me tell you
something. It's always the Muslims.
Bro, it's Let me tell you something.
Bro, bro.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Bro, bro, listen. I'm
I'm trying to say to him Akhi, listen to
me. He's taking like I'm an idiot. And
only that, it's always these Muslims
that got issues. Akhi, anyone who
attacks our
I don't know.
But anyways, forget him, it, the police
are coming. What?
You can't make this You can't
Yeah. I think we're officially the first
UK streamers and you're not even a
streamer. Yeah. To get swatted.
Say what? Remember before we went to the
letter, I'm like, "Oh no, if something
happens to American
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, he's telling me.
I didn't want to say it because I didn't
want to give anyone any ideas. Bro, that
is crazy, bro. This guy is trying You
know what it is?
It's
It's just like he wants fame.
Like You know what it is? He knows very
well, yeah? And And I spoke to him. I'm
like, "I'm so sorry." Before I was
assuming the best. Now I'm so sorry,
bro, you're doing it for attention.
Yeah? You're doing it for attention.
Okay? And apparently he was he was
stalking them yesterday. Yeah, yeah,
bro. Um Like why would you do that? Bro,
I told him, "You want to come studio?"
That's Tell them to keep an eye out to
see if anyone's following them. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, no, I need to I need to It's
Allah.
And he goes, "Man, they're
Allah, it's so
You're a Muslim, bro. It's Ramadan.
Allah,
I did Sorry, brother. We had one Muslim
guy trying to cause problems for us.
Not a problem. In Ramadan. Welcome, bro.
Make sure no one's following you guys.
Yeah, no, no one.
Okay, okay, no problem. Okay, all right,
all right. All right, see you guys soon.
Yeah, I'm good. We're good. We're good,
yeah.
All right, take care. It's all good.
We was in there
Guys, we're trying to do stuff
that will help the youth, that will help
the youngsters. We're doing
Actually,
let me tell you something.
I have never had
a Look, look, look. Maybe a Zionist,
a Christian,
a Rastafarian,
a a a Jew or Hindu or Sikh that has
tried to harm us.
You're a Muslim. What do you want? We
told you, brother, leave it. Stop
insulting. It's Ramadan. You're
swearing. You're cursing. You're
insulting.
For what?
For what? Some attention? You got it You
got it. You happy now?
You want to come to the studio, but I
didn't even know who you was.
I I said, "Yeah, no problem." Not
knowing that you were Allah.
You're coming and you're insulting us.
It's Ramadan and
>> [snorts]
>> subhanallah yesterday apparently you did
the same thing.
Yesterday apparently you did the same
thing.
Why? I can't understand. What do you get
out of it?
What do you get out of it? Unnecessary.
Wallahi unnecessary fitna.
We are teaching people how to pray. And
every time they pray, you get to share
in that reward. And when they teach
their children and their children's
children
the reward continues. Every Fajr Zuhr
Asr Maghrib Isha Every recitation for
just £100 you can help teach 20 to 60
people
>> like me learn how to pray salah. Donate
today.